[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
my
[Music]
so
uh can you guys hear me can you guys
hear me
am i being heard am i loud and clear
what's going on man what's going on i i
assume you guys can hear me i don't know
i don't want to wait for the uh for for
the background man
we we gotta we gotta double check
got to double check what you guys doing
man what what are you
playing waiting for the guests right now
i figured i'd come in here pop in a
little early
talk a little bit you know see how
everything's going man
do a little mic check one two three
three two one
everything seems pretty good on that end
turn my
headphones up look man
i am pretty sure let me check my of all
my my levels man my levels is in the
yellow
it should be fine we should
be fine should be no issues
let me go ahead and share this to
twitter man let me share this to twitter
gotta tell gotta tell the the realm that
we are
we are live
there we go now you gotta go to the iop
account i gotta
i gotta retweet it on the iop account
man i got to
there we go all right so what are you
guys doing man what are you playing i
i'm curious what you guys are playing
because i'm playing often by mass effect
i i have an absurd amount of mass effect
done turn up the base
look man i don't know if you're being
sarcastic
i don't know if you really feel like i
should turn something up
we can't we can't have the sarcasm when
i'm just trying to figure out what's
going on
can't have that going on we cannot have
that going on
all right so it looks like everything's
fine with that
everything's fine man so
i did i have played through mass effect
one and two
get that right out there man um
great game man great game i think i'm
gonna do an attic
spotlight on mass effect one two and
three because i do have a lot of um
a lot of nitpicks like a lot a lot of
nitpicks
and i don't think the games are bad by
any means
i don't think they're by by any means
final fantasy 10 on game pass
great game yes if you're a fan of final
fantasy or turn based in general
go over there and try out that final
fantasy 10 man
probably not so much just final fantasy
x2
but you could definitely try 10 i would
definitely very
thing say try 10. so you know we're
waiting for the uh
got got a cow from tit network coming
over he should be here any moment
so you know we'll wait for him actually
i think they they ask me when people
join or not
so i gotta keep kind of keep track on
that don't want him just sitting in the
uh
the waiting room all day that would be
horrible
so what what what topic did you guys
come here for which one
is it the wv games the star field
or the new xbox games in development
which one
which one is it i'm curious
no it's not going to be a solo show i'm
waiting
for my guest but i figured i'd come in
here and talk man
i still have four minutes you guys have
an additional
four minutes that you shouldn't have man
how is what game mass effect
is that the game that you're talking
about
the oh the wb games topic i thought
people would be here for the star-filled
one man wb
you guys are in for some wb man
guys want that w b talk don't you it's
okay
it's okay
we we will definitely talk about wb
we'll definitely talk about wb
wb clearly got some stuff going on over
there man i don't know what but they got
some stuff going on
one thing you guys are gonna have to
excuse me for is my voice
is crumbling
and we'll just you guys i'll have to
to to bear with me man you have to bear
with me
my voice is definitely not 100 there
i need you to inject the new games into
my veins i think everyone needs the new
games into their veins
it's been kind of dry out for uh for
first party xbox
i mean i've been playing plenty of games
you know uh
i just got through playing octopi travel
shout out to game pass
uh i'm playing mass effect one and two
and three
which i've been playing that pretty much
non-stop for
for a week and i'm still at the
beginning of mass effect 3.
no topics really just listen you got a
good time with no competition that i
know of
yeah that's why i chose tuesday i
usually try to be out of here before
before rdx goes live because obviously
i'm gonna
see a massive decrease in viewership if
i'm still going on when uh diller and
the fam over there going
so that's why i try to try to get out of
here before before that happens
so i got a question if starfield is xbox
only and it shows xbox one
look man what when the show starts we'll
get into that stuff
got a lot to talk about today sega call
cam
warner brothers i don't know i feel like
there is
a let me go ahead
and
there we go give me one second
what's up can you hear me
can you hear me
you might want to change your name too
because uh
i'm muted i i
i blocked the screen for being shown
because i don't know if you want that
name out there like that
give me one second you guys he's got to
fix stuff on his end
so just out of curiosity while he gets
stuff going man
just out of curiosity how do you guys
feel
about this intro how do you feel about
it man i
cuz i like it i feel like i do need to
get some additional music made with it i
i think i definitely feel like
it's the direction the way i want to go
but i do need
i need an additional beat right now you
know uh
i'm going to probably have looked at
here probably the next couple months
but right now i feel like it's fine the
way it is
but how do you guys feel about this
starting soon screen
i didn't even really announce it too
much i just bam popped it up
you're playing yakuza 5 yakuza 5 i
haven't played any of those old yakuza
games
being told they're good though man being
told they're good
great intro i like the intro man uh i i
see i don't
i'm i'm gonna have an overlay made
which i mean i guess i could lower you
guys like the beat so much man hold up
hold up there you go
you can have the beat man the beat in
the background
while i wait for my for for my guest to
get ready you can have the bee
sauces look man
it took it took me a couple weeks to to
get this made
but i like it i like it i think it's a a
very solid intro
if i say so myself it's pretty much how
i envisioned it i just got to get the uh
oh no i'm not having an intro mate i'm
having an overlay made
me being hyped i don't know man
i already put myself too up much out
there man maybe i want to keep those
those those bites of me being hyped
maybe i want to keep that close to the
chest
a melodic beat like what do you mean by
that uh born distracted i'm kind of
curious
i'm reading the chat because i'm waiting
for uh for the guest
but he'll be along shortly just chill
chill with the chill with the realm
so i i i don't know how many of you guys
watch the the streams i did a return
did you guys enjoy that because it's
just it was a trial basic that i was
wanting to try
i'm probably going to move that to
twitch on the iop twitch
how do you guys feel about that do you
guys think i should still do it here
because it was getting a lot
on the on the youtube channel and i i
don't want to like
crowd it with nothing but let's plays
and streams i feel like twitch is the
most
the more appropriate place for stuff
like that
electronic what do you mean by that
oh okay i get what you're saying i don't
know i'll see i'm going to look into it
killer instinct we're going to talk
about that man we're going to talk about
that
give it about a couple more minutes and
we'll get the the show on the road man
we'll get the show on the road
uh okay definitely must hustle and
motivate
said that the the streams were fun they
were fun to watch
we got some stuff that we're doing on
the iop side
that's going to improve a lot overall
got a two dollar super chat from uh
davin james do you think microsoft will
purchase wb
no but i don't know man we don't know
what's going on with microsoft
um they have split uh wb
they're going through a lot of like
transitioning right now so i'm kind of
curious exactly
what's going to happen in the long term
when it comes to the uh to these
properties
to my knowledge if they did buy wb
someone in the chat if you if you're
aware do
do they get the mortal kombat license do
they own that or they just contract that
out i don't know
very because i know that's a wb and they
kind of just put the movie so i kind of
feel like they own the license but i
don't know
someone informed me put that in the chat
educate me
i finally got returned found it on sale
for 50
because of a crazy doesn't bother me
i have it digitally
the only thing missing for the xbox
portfolio at this point is a push
of the fighting game genre 100 agree
with you
and that's why i feel like if uh because
it looked like they were
they that wb
might sell individual studios it looks
like microsoft might be able to come in
get that nether realm and then just
leave
okay so get the the mk the mortal kombat
license but
none of the dlc i got you all right of
the dc stuff
that's fine you know maybe they could
license that but
i think they need the mortal kombat
license to make that netherrealm
purchase
make a little bit of sense
no if if they bought the mortal kombat
thing they would probably get that
license
because that would be one of the things
that would make that appealing to even
buy
is the um the mortal kombat thing i i
don't think they would buy
warner brothers without that license i
mean clearly they want to do a
they want to do their own version
of killer instinct and they need a
studio to do that but to me
they would need that mortal kombat
license
but it got tucked in the discount so
they have a little
yeah you you got a point there but i
don't think
that it's one of those scenarios where
they got to spend the money like
they they had enough
set aside to buy tick-tock and the
moment that fell through because keep in
mind
they try to buy discord right after they
try to buy tick-tock that didn't work
out for them
and the the discord thing fell through
so i don't think it's like they have all
this money just sitting around i think
it's one of those scenarios that
they are they would just spend it it's
not like
if oh because they have all this money
that they took out
for tick tock that they have to spend it
like they don't have to spend it
fighting games and persona games i'ma be
honest
i don't know man i don't know
it seems my guest has uh has left oh
there he is coming back
there we go what's up shadowblade
appreciate the uh the support man
appreciate the support you guys
what's up
i i have no clue you you change your
we're having a little technical issues
you guys just give me a brief moment
technical issues man we'll get we'll get
going here in a second
some technical issues see see this is my
fault for going live early to talk to
you guys
because now we have to figure out the
technical issues live on the show
we might have to go to discord to be
honest with you guys
i'm not going to keep going into this if
we have to go to discord man it's okay
it's fine
so let's read some more of this this
fine chat going on right now
discovery wants everything but the video
game division from oh it's what sound
like
oh but the video game division so if
they bought them
what would end up happening is they
would end up selling that division
anyway
or would they not buy them if they if if
they had to buy the video game division
or would warner brother can wp games
continue
to exist on their side but the division
buys everything else
curious man curious gotta gotta know
everything going on man gotta know
everything going on
so what we'll go ahead and do
is while he fixes his audio issues we'll
go ahead and start the first topic
now there's three topics there i'm
curious which ones you guys want first
do you want you know what i ain't
letting you guys pick
we gonna pick the new games in
development for xbox that that's what
we're gonna go with first
there's been a lot of talk about games
that are being developed behind closed
doors on xbox
and we got arcane with some vampire game
we got this typhoon thing
and we got the dragon thing over there
in her io interactive
so we have all these all these games
being developed for microsoft that's not
even really being developed
by the core studios of microsoft besides
arcane studios
so my question to you guys
is out of all these
all these things i just mentioned all
the things that you've seen on twitter
that's realistic what games
are you guys most excited about because
me it's arcane
with it's arcane with the uh the vampire
life
i feel like arcane is such an underrated
studio
and we need more of that in our lives in
my life personally
i don't know about you guys but i need
more of that in my life
i want to hear what you guys want in
your life
with these studios which one excites you
the most
i'll wait a couple seconds to get on
there
just diary looks fun sort of got that
sin but oh people
the arcane game for me yeah i feel like
arcane
is such an underrated studio and
you know obviously some people don't
like dishonored omen
okay so it is omen i forgot about this
so the name is omen
i feel like some people don't really
appreciate what arcane is
and arcane is such a valuable studio
and people don't really put a lot of
structure behind arcane
if that makes sense to you guys give me
one moment
someone's knocking at my door
so
can you hear me
that that's that's fine uh you know i
don't even really hear them that much
but yeah so right now what we're talking
about
i want to make sure this that everyone
can hear me all right everything's fine
right now what we're talking about cows
we're talking about
the the the studios and the games that
microsoft has been
going for them like the iowa interactive
with the dragon symbol the typhoon which
i have no clue what that is
and obviously the omen with arcane which
one of those
excites you the most definitely the only
with arcane
now you know i've been hearing that
arcane is supposedly working on some
type of vampire game
and to me that's the big deal last hot
vampire game i played was probably
uh legacy of kang and soul reaver
i tried to play vampire vampire controls
the kind of wonky
story was okay but still you know it was
a mid
you know double a type title so it
really wasn't too
too special um
other than that i mean i don't play
another vampire masquerade games so i
don't know what they're like
but at the end of the day man um i think
if arcane worked with a vampire game
it'd be perfect for them
yeah i feel like arcane is such an
underrated studio for multiple reasons
because arcane's always been one of
those studios
that i feel like their games just go
over people's head because
a lot of people don't really you know
it's not that people don't like that
type of gameplay people
i feel like their type of gameplay has
always been stealth mechanic and i do
feel like
that type of gameplay is least popular
with a lot of people would you agree
with that
oh yeah i would i would agree with that
yeah so you know one of the biggest
things that uh you know
let's talk about this this cyclone man
what is this cyclo do you have any idea
what the cyclone
rumor of this game is no i have no idea
like it it reminds me of uh that game
that they had obsidian make back in the
day storm lands
anytime you see cyclone you think of
storms so they could be anything
honestly
and then i saw i made a video about it
on youtube and you know how many people
in the comments section was like
ubisoft ubisoft and i get it
cyclone the ubisoft i get it there is
some kind of connection with it with
their logo and stuff but it's just like
i don't think that's it like i have no
clue what cyclone is
i've really tried to get this info it
but p there's people i know that have
the info
but they don't want to give me the info
and that's curious because
i get a lot of you know insider
information that i don't really come out
openly
and talk about obviously because you
don't want to make people upset
but the crazy part is the fact that no
one will give me this info
if that makes sense to you like what is
so popular
that we can announce uh drag the dragon
thing for w not wb io interactive
but no one wants to tell me what this
cyclone is about
no one does i mean maybe it's a bigger
game
listen a lot of you got to think a lot
of these third party games
that microsoft have these developers
working on i
i don't expect them to be like big big
first party type aaa games i think
they'll be i think honestly i think
they'll be
like double a maybe mid-tier upper
mid-tier titles
um i think microsoft is really putting
all their money
into first party um and into those first
party studios honestly so
uh you know the io game dragon game
whatever that is
i'm sure it'll be really really good
that's probably a couple years
we could be something too but i don't
know we'll see yeah i think i think the
dragon thing's not going to come out for
a while
but i think the reason no one's wanting
to tell me the cyclone thing
is because we i think that's about to
get announced like i i think
most of the time when people try to hide
information and they're not really up
right
up front about it it's because it's
about to get announced and they don't
want to
they don't want to fear the the actual
game getting ruined from the
announcement you know what i'm saying
and i think i think this game is a lot
more development than people think and i
think we could potentially see it this
year
i don't know man i mean microsoft
definitely needs something besides halo
that's for sure
if starfield's being pushed to 2022 then
um they definitely need something to
line up with halo
um i don't know if forza motorsport 8 is
going to drop this year
i kind of felt like if they dropped halo
in starfield that would have been two
bombs
maybe you could have dropped starfield
then let's say
december or october with halo usually
dropping in november
that would have been really great um and
then the forza usually comes out of
september
but if they have some third party
content they should definitely release
it
um you know in the fall september
september october november with halo so
that way they got a good lineup for the
fall
i think we're gonna see we're going to
see
a forza horizon this year i don't think
we're going to see a motor sports
well you st you're going to get horizon
yeah nah i doubt that
don't don't don't don't comfortable with
that
i think we'll get motorsport before we
get horizon i think we'll get motorsport
next year we get horizon this year
two horizons back to back that's weird
no to motorsport next year and horizon
this year we didn't get a horizon last
year well that but the last forza game
that dropped was forza horizon
yeah i feel like there's a reason for
that because they want to re
they want to look horizon is definitely
the most popular one let's just be
honest
so i feel like the reason that
motorsports was
put back so many so many years is
because i think they're rebuilding that
game from the ground up because they
they they they know the casual one's
going to be the most popular but i don't
think they like
how how did how much of a gap there is
between
you know what i'm saying yeah but i just
feel like
motorsport right now that drop would be
ideal
to me that would be especially showing
off a new engine
microsoft really needs something that's
going to push
the xbox series x and uh
motorsport honestly should be a next-gen
only game
which i believe it is yeah so that will
be an extra only and that's part of the
reason i feel like it's coming out next
year
that's why i'm saying this should come
out this year because this is one of the
few titles
that they have that hasn't been on the
xbox one so i feel like if they put it
on
uh xbox uh series x only it gives them
some sort
of push for the holiday season like we
have a next-gen
you know motorsport or whatever and
didn't push horizon next year
uh you know i i just i just find it i
mean if you're going to do a rotation i
feel like they should stick with the
rotation
and not do back-to-backs because forza
horizon 4 is actually still doing really
well selling extremely well on steam
really high population still you know
one of them
better played games on xbox so um i
think
i think it's time for motorsport and for
us to see some new new uh
details and engines and find out what
they got going on with the uh
sport eight do you think it's a
possibility horizons uh
if verizon does come out this year if it
might be just an xbox series x and s
exclusive
well i mean obviously no but no if that
comes out that's definitely
question without question that's
definitely going to be a crushing game
yeah that's definitely going to be
crushed in game yeah
i feel like when it comes to uh horizon
i feel like they they they want to
restructure
motorsports uh and then plus let's be
real
right now there's not a whole lot coming
out this year besides halo
it does look like starfield might be
pushed back to the beginning of 2022
so it would be to me it would make the
most sense that
if they can release one of the the right
the forza games
it would be the most popular one you get
what i'm saying because
that will reach the bigger audience uh i
think they can
always show what this this system can do
with that
because horizons have always looked very
impressive
and i think they'll be able to do that
just as easy with verizon
is that they do with motorsport i don't
know man i feel like and i'll be honest
with you
i kind of feel like when it comes to
uh crosston games the difference
graphically
is not that significant i've noticed
that with a lot of games
excuse me i had to cough um i kind of
feel like when i look at some of these
cross-gen games
a lot of the times yeah you you know if
you go into detail
obviously you're going to see you know
significant differences whether there's
lighting
shadows uh more you know more objects on
screen
whether it's puddles bushes trees you
know those are things that
obviously if you compare the two you
will notice but just from uh
just looking at the screen or just
looking at what's happening i just don't
think that
you know question titles graphically are
a significant difference which is why i
feel like
having next-gen only titles makes more
sense
um ford ford to to release because it's
really not the biggest gap
between the two consoles is going to be
those frames you know 120
60 whereas the series uh the xbox one is
only going to do like 30
maybe 60 at the most so i think that's
gonna be probably the biggest
significant difference
and that's why i think motorsport halo
and maybe another title
uh from third party drops this holiday
that would be big for microsoft
yeah i definitely understand when it
comes to stuff like that
now let's roll this back a little bit uh
in terms of
you know i personally feel like i uh i
owe interactive
i love the hitman games but i've never
thought they were like anything
spectacular like i know a lot of people
love three and that's cool
three was definitely a great looking
game but the way
they use dragon and the way that they're
describing this game it's not going to
be anything like it man uh
do you think that that that might be a
little bit of a mistake because i feel
like i
interact as a part is a good studio but
they they do good at what they do
if part of me is like can they really go
out of that stealth mechanic that
they've done
i'm kind of really nervous about that
because i like i might like hit man
but i don't know if they could do
anything besides it man i know that
might be taking a little away from them
but and mainly a lot of that's just
because i don't know
what the game is going to be i don't
know
how far this game is i don't know if
they're hiring people to do this
and the fact that they're using codename
dragon or whatever it is
it makes me kind of feel like it might
be some kind of fantasy game and
it's so i don't know if there's too many
studios that could switch back and forth
from like drastically what they're doing
do you think either actor is one of them
i don't be honest with you i don't know
i know i o interactive makes hitman
that's probably the only thing i've ever
seen them make but they
are game developers it's not to say they
can't make a different
uh type of game you know different
design
game um but you do
you do have to question whether
them going into this realm because
obviously when you when you talk about
drag as you think about fantasy
them going into this realm of fantasy uh
the question is whether or not they can
actually pull this off after doing a
stealth game for so long
it would be pretty cool if they use
their stealth
game mechanics for the game as well
whether it's some type of ninja game or
greek mythology game or you know
whatever it is that they're going to be
using um
with dragons i think that would be kind
of cool but
yeah i would question it honestly we
have no idea what they're going to do
how they're going to do it
and if they even capable of doing it um
because they've been working on hitman
for so long
but yeah i can't i can't go too much
into it because
i do feel like every developer is
capable of doing
a different game uh we'll have to see
exactly how they handle it
if they hire new talent to do it because
i think that's the biggest key
is are they going to hire people or they
feel like they go off with the talent
currently in the studio
uh clearly i think they're going to have
to hire new people
and clearly this dragon thing one would
think microsoft's funding
it because they're still making that
double-oh-seven game i don't know if
they're going to make another hitman
game right now
but to me they would have to hire
additional studio because i don't know
if that studio can handle
what they're wanting to do with that
much output with two projects going in
at the same time
i don't know how many people is working
there
but you know we'll have to see i have to
check it out right now actually let me
see
i have a lot of hope in it with io
interactive i do feel like they're
they're a very good studio it's just i
don't know what they can do if they're
not
in that stealth mechanic way
but you know hopefully you know this
would be
one of those horizon zero dawn moments
where
they they go out of their comfort zone
and they make a killer game
well here's the thing io interactive
employs 200 people as of january 2021
and they have two subsidiary studios io
uh malamo sweden and io barcelona
uh yeah barcelona and spain so
so they have people they have two
studios so they probably have one studio
working on double o seven in one studio
working on the dragon game and sweden
seems like the ideal team that will be
working on
the dragon game it's going to be
interesting man
i think cal would you not as like
the best thing about being in the xbox
ecosystem
right now is the is the unknown like
absolutely used to be and you know we've
been doing this a while man it used to
be
we would go into these e3s and we would
know exactly what they're gonna show up
there
we will know exactly what's gonna be on
that stage what the announcements are
i couldn't even tell you what they're
gonna open up e3 with this year i don't
know
i'm trying to tell you i remember uh i
don't know you know it's been a minute
since i've podcast but
one of my shows way back in the day and
i was saying that look the best thing
about microsoft right now
is the fact that we don't know what they
have that's the most exciting thing
because you can't anticipate what
they're going to show
most most shows we would know oh we're
gonna probably see halo
uh we're probably gonna see gears of war
you know the same
uh you know the same basic four
three games that they normally show uh
something of
and then you get a bunch of indie titles
some mid-tier third-party titles that
aren't exclusive that are probably timed
and that's about it but this time around
with all these studios
it's just it's just i just think that
there's so much
excuse me there's so much to show
um and i'm sure there's not enough to
show
uh because some games are still in early
production but there's just so much to
show over the next couple of years that
anything could pop up on stage and you
will be surprised now we know about some
games like about
we know about state of decay 3 which i
truly hope they really make a triple a
title
i hope it's not like a double a mid-tier
game as usual
i think that they need their a
exp like keep the world it is how how
expansive it is
and build out that world don't try to
make it bigger stadium k is big enough
or b if they don't want to go that far
lower the the amount of the how big that
game is
and really make the game feel alive make
it more linear
it's not linear it's like if right now
state of decay's maps are are gigantic
right and if if they don't have the
necessary funds to really
go off with these and make them like
really unique
and you know fill out the world maybe we
can get a city instead of a small town
you know what i'm saying like right
right like instead of doing that you
know let's
let's let's cut it back you know instead
of being a town let's have a city
because you're not you're not happen to
do this giant
place they had three maps in that so you
know instead of
focusing all your attention to make
three big maps
make one really high dense map that has
a huge population
in it that that you can actually feel
like it's a zombie apocalypse
i feel like be honest with you i feel
like they need to make the game more
linear and and
uh i mean it could be open world in a
way but i just feel like
the character models need to be upgraded
to
uh something maybe more third-person
over-the-shoulder
uh type title um the the character
models need to be a little bit more
realistic
um i really didn't think they need to
take state of decay 3
into the next level of design
you know what i'm saying like you've had
this envyish looking type title for such
a long time
and this it has it has its fan base
but i just think that the title could be
so much bigger
if you could if you made the the the
world
more realistic and the character designs
more realistic i think the most the spec
the most special thing about that game
isn't so much the open world
but the survivor aspects well that and
the fact that they had dynamic
narratives
for the story i actually feel like
that's always hurt them
i feel like you don't when you don't
have
people love stories but they don't love
to make the story
themselves let's be real here like you
know see thieves
uh you know people people want a good
narrative to toad to them
but they don't have to use their
imagination for it to be told to them
i mean but i think that i i thought that
it was one of those things at least the
last time i spoke to one of the devs
from state of decay
was that the narrative dynamic narrative
was that when you meet people and the
things that you do within the game
uh you know it changes the storyline
changes so nobody's story is the same
because
every interaction is different for each
person or each individual because the
people that's
that you meet is random you don't say
like randomly generated or whatever
i just think if they did something like
that that would be pretty cool
um if they haven't done that already and
they need to just
upgrade everything honestly and just
push it to the next level microsoft
needs to push
all their games to the next level going
forward they want to have mid-tier indie
titles that's fine but it should be all
third-party
i feel like most of their first party
should be should be
making high quality games exactly except
for
you know the double fines and stuff like
that the smaller the smaller things like
compulsion games or
um you know double fine i think
composer's making a triple a title
i think they're making one too which i
wouldn't be surprised uh
they're very talented studio we just
haven't gotten a chance to really see
what they can do yet
yeah one thing i would like for the
because i personally want a banjo
that's what i want like i want a banjo
i get it rare is doing what they do let
double fight make a banjo
that'd be cool i think double fine could
easily make a banjo double fine
already makes mad platformers i'll be
honest with you
the way microsoft and nintendo work
together i would ask nintendo to make
banjo
so that would be one of those things if
you guys make it it comes out for xbox
but it also comes out for the swiss
switch i wouldn't mind that
that would be one give that would be one
thing i would do i feel like nintendo
and microsoft work together very well
they put a lot of their
not a lot but they put a couple games on
there um
and you know it seems that they have a
really solid working relationship you
don't really see
nintendo and playstation working
together like that that would be
crazy if they can create they co-develop
the game
yeah co-develop banjo and then they
release on switch and xbox
obviously xbox would have the better
graphics and all that stuff like that
you know
but do you think them having to make it
for the switch would make the the xbox
version
like worse by by default no no
absolutely not i don't think so i mean
it would be no different than
them putting oreo on the xbox or oreo on
a switch you know what i'm saying is
you just have to go and have nintendo
work on it have their
you know look nintendo makes the best
platforms in the world there's a reason
why
people gravitate to their first party
and why those prices in those games
never drop you know they're incredible
when it comes to platformers so you know
you get the king of platformers
and microsoft has a ton of platformers
that's the thing
out of all of the out of the three big
three out of the big three
nintendo and microsoft are truly the
only two
that truly have an expansive amount of
platformers
because microsoft owns rear and rear has
a lot of platformers now over the years
they've tried to take advantage of some
of those platformers we've had the
banjos
you've seen obviously recently you've
seen uh you know battle toads
which you know a lot of people didn't
like i didn't have a problem thinking
after the game was solid
um you got conquered because you got
cameo you got
like there's a lot of games you got
sabers there's a lot of old school games
that they still own that they haven't
even brought to life yet you know what
i'm saying so
i just feel like you know if you if you
work with them
on some of these platformers microsoft
can really have a
good round of games that will appeal to
all people you know kids and adults
while still pushing
their adults and not to mention three
not to mention that
you know because obviously there's not
game pass open on the switch so
they're they're going to sell a lot on
the switch if there's a banjo on this
right right exactly so i mean i think
that was a big deal you already got a
banjo on super smash bros
so it just to me makes sense like
nintendo's nintendo
i would say microsoft has been very uh
that's what i'm looking for they've been
very generous with
nintendo and literally giving them
giving them a lot nintendo hasn't done
anything for microsoft
anything at all so that way i wouldn't
mind a trade-off yeah well at least that
we know of right now but
you know you got two worry games you got
banjo and you're
in your game i think i don't really have
like master chief or something or
another character like that
that's going to get announced that
they're going yeah there's a minecraft
character on there
it's rumored that master chief's going
on the switch which yeah at this point
they might as well
like they've already put a couple things
on the switch so
let's let's go ahead and get to the to
to the meat and potatoes we're gonna
we're gonna do the the wb game things
last because there's a lot to go over
with that uh let's talk about star field
probably not coming in 2021 i feel
personally like
as long as this game doesn't come out
like like
spur like next summer or like summer's
pushing it
but like summerish to to to the fall
it getting delayed a couple months isn't
a big deal like because
what people are gonna like once when
halo drops in october november
they're like as long as starfield does
it comes out before next
march i personally feel like it's not
gonna be a big deal i think
people are still going to be able to
play the fall games because let's be
real here
probably 20 fall games dropping this
fall and then they're going to have
star field to look forward to at the
beginning of next year what do you feel
about that guy
i think that's listen i i feel like once
microsoft gets the ball rolling it's a
wrap
that's how i feel um obviously starfield
is supposed to be a big game we haven't
seen it we really don't know much about
it
um we just know it's coming from
bethesda and just based on
what we know about bethesda we believe
that it should be
a really huge and good game
um you know hopefully it's not too not
buggy or anything like that but
we believe it's supposed to be a really
good game uh
microsoft still has a lot of games
that's dropping obviously you have
stalker you got halo
you got the ascent coming out and i
think it's june which i'm
very looking forward to um there's a
there's a couple third-party
mid you know mid titles dropping uh
so the fall should be okay it's not
gonna be
it's not gonna be killer um but it
should be okay overall
i just think that if they drop starfield
let's say in march
they definitely need something in
february um
but once their games start going i think
that it's going to be
it's going to be great it's going to be
a great generation for microsoft i've
always said
like clearly we we got you know
competition sony's still here
you know there's no denying that they've
been very successful
but i always tell people i'm like look
i'm not saying sony's in trouble when
microsoft gets this engine going
but all i'm saying is you have 23
studios in like 40 teams
sooner or later even that the the
average
joe that works at walmart gonna notice
the difference in games
at some point when you're subscribing to
game pass and you're playing stuff more
consistently more constantly
people that you that you're friends with
like why are you always playing xbox
dude they always drop and stuff
like i it it's word of mouth and i feel
like
because people keep saying to this day
cal that sony don't need to buy nothing
so he can do exactly what they're doing
now and be fine
i'm like they can't because it's not
what it was last generation
when you have bethesda games and
microsoft studios games
starting to work together and fill up
this gap
and it keeps coming out over and over
again every three months another game
every two months another double a game
every month
an indie game and every every now and
then they put a third-party game
day and date there's going to be a
difference in how the scene is
oh i i was i was like you could comment
on that
okay my bad uh no well listen i think
i think microsoft uh i said this before
i think when these games come out
they're trying to go for like one big
triple title triple a title every
quarter
right and in between that you have some
of these mid-tier double-a games
that's kind of supposed to hold you down
in between a combination of them working
with third party and indies
you know we we get a game let's say like
we get a game like tunic in january
you get a mid-tier game uh you know
let's say in february and then you get
start filled
in march and if you continue to do that
that is an insane amount of releases
and a great way to produce content
and i'm like i'm looking at things like
by the time those four
games hit you could release two or three
triple a titles at the end of every year
you know in my mind i'm like
you could do halo forza motorsport
and something from bethesda the next
year you could do
fable uh uh forza horizon
and then something from bethesda yeah
after that you could do years of war
like
but like the rotation the rotation for
the holiday season would be
absolutely insane for at least the next
five to six years
the way games should be released and you
got to think what's funny is
by the time all these companies a
studios are done
the bd studios are going to be ready and
by the time that b studios are done the
a studio's going to be back up
like like i i just i don't think people
realize that the amount of content that
microsoft's
going to attempt i'm saying attempt
obviously we got to see
it delivered but the amount of content
that microsoft is going to attempt to
deliver
it is going to be great and the thing is
is like
they don't even need to hit them all you
get a couple really good really good
games that's not like that
that god of war caliber not necessarily
in height but you know
in quality you get uh you know i don't
think i think stated k
is going to run around between the
double and triple a i don't think right
right
i think it just depends on what they do
i think compulsion
people are sleeping on compulsion but i
think compulsion is going to surprise a
lot of people
uh i i believe double fine is going to
continuously
throw out every six months to a year
because they got a lot of
people working for them they're gonna
throw out a lot of weird titles yeah
it's quirky games
uh those platform type titles that's
what they're gonna be throwing out i
expect them to do that and then
obviously the initiative and what's
funny is i literally just named nothing
but microsoft studios
i didn't name arcane i didn't name um uh
machine guns none of them
right i honestly feel like right now
all last generation cal we always like
man
uh you know it's looking a little spooky
but now it's just like
i i couldn't i really could not give a
better scenario microsoft can be in
obviously they can own bigger studios
like maybe square enix or sega
but it's just like they bought bethesda
and
that's that's a huge feat that was a
whole publisher
and yeah yeah i agree i i i just look at
it like microsoft
um they're looking at game pass and and
the catalog
they need to build to be consistent um
and have people subscribe to it
i constantly getting to argue with with
some guys about this like
recently i had gotten to a little debate
with a with a dude
who was like um god of war
and uh horizon zero dawn made 500
million at 400 million respectively
and i told him i said listen if
playstation did a day and date god of
war
and charge you 10 bucks a month and you
had 20 million people
on ps now you've made 200 million
in one month yeah people don't realize
that
2.4 billion in 12 months
right but you know and i'm sitting up
there i'm saying to myself like think
about the amount of revenue
you would be generating at that point
like there's a reason why microsoft does
this but the reason why sony can't do it
or at least i believe or most people
believe they can't do this because
they can't take the hit there's going to
be a period which is what microsoft is
going through now
where you're building your base and
obviously it's not going to right you're
spending a lot of money to to get people
to subscribe
and obviously it's going to take a while
for that bass to sort of expand and
start generating they went through the
same thing with the the cloud disputing
servers
like you know when you expand it and it
depends on how big you do it
and they didn't they didn't they didn't
pull shots like they
i don't know how much sony's worth but
it's arguably that they're spending more
to build game pass for the future than
sony's worth
like and that's kind of crazy that
they're spending
that amount of money and you know
people's like oh you know square enix
can't
uh they can't buy square enix talking
about uh sony and it's like
i think sony could buy square enix but
how
first off you have to get you have to
get through the higher ups
that's a huge risk because unlike sony
unlike microsoft
sony don't have that type of money just
lying around
they would probably have to liquidate
some assets or take out loans
because i i sure they might have a few
billion dollars in cash laying around
but do they want to spend all of that
money because that's probably all of
sony
sony's more than just gaming
right so you know i honestly feel like
wb games you know we're going to get to
here in a minute
that i think that's up for the table i
think starfield right now
is what they need to be focusing on they
need to make sure starfield comes out
in a very good state at e3
right they need to have todd howard go
up there with his he makes everything
sound so great
it just works like obviously it didn't
work but at the time people thought it
did because of him saying that
i think that they need they need that
game to come out
and it needs to wow people right right
right i i
i think that uh obviously starfield is a
big deal um we've been waiting for this
game for a minute we've heard about it i
remember being at
uh bethesda's event and it got in that
e3 and yeah when they got announced
which was pretty awesome
i think that was the first year i went
was the year i think it was the first
year you went yeah
um but it was pretty cool man
and uh his was his was crazy first i
want to answer one of the questions
one of the guys in the chat had asked
they were saying that
that um you know game pass has been out
for a while why are people still
choosing nintendo and sony
and uh the reason why or at least one of
the reasons why
is that you hear a lot of people say
there's nothing in there about old games
the reality of it is is i can guarantee
you that a lot of the playstation fans
who hate
xbox have played a lot of xbox's old
games
they probably played gears of war
they've played halo they've probably
tried forza
they've done these games before so
jumping into game pass is
not ideal that's why it's so important
going to this generation
that they release all these new games
that haven't been in game pass
and you know once you're starting to get
these new titles
that's sort of you know having this
snowball effect
coming in month after month after month
after month from first party
that's when you'll start to see a real
big uptake and subscriptions their goal
is to get one person in game pass for
one particular game
people are going to join game pass this
fall for halo it's going to be insane
and then by the time they're done with
halo or at least come to the point where
they don't play it every day
starfield's going to launch and by the
time star field's done
whatever in summer is going to launch
and by the time whatever they're doing
this summer's going to launch
whatever in the fall is going to launch
right once you start getting games like
a valve
and you start getting your skyr uh your
elder scrolls
and you obviously got starfield once you
start getting your your forzas and
you know your gears of wars once you
start getting these big
aaa titles coming from all these studios
perfect dark or whatever
fable you'll start to see people
subscribe to play these games
and you're going to start to see big
upticks and subscriptions
right now microsoft is heavily
heavily relying on third party that's
why you're starting to see a lot of
third-party support
um you're starting to see some games
that just came out hit
uh game pass a few months later things
like that so
and they're trying to get third party
day and date like they did with nlb and
they did with um
what's the outriders um so i wouldn't be
surprised they if they continue to do
more of that but once the first party
hit you're gonna see a big uptick
in subscriptions yeah so we got a two
dollar super chat from shrimp kingdom
cow l you are missed remember when phil
was on tech
thanks brother i appreciate it i had to
take a hiatus man i was
i was completely burped out and with the
coving situation i've had to stay home
and homeschool my kid
for like the entire year so i just
couldn't do the podcast and thing but i
will be back in august
um coming out as a solo podcaster with
superpower shots will be returning
yeah i've always you're one of the very
few people
that can do stuff alone i i can do it
alone but man it's so hard
like i said they're like like when i
when i know i have to do
an attic show by myself i will literally
have like
20 things to talk about like and what's
funny is like my mind just talks so fast
i go through them and i'm like well it's
been 40 minutes i guess i'll talk to you
guys later like
like you'll make it it's it's like it's
like you're talking to yourself
like it not like a bad way it's like
it's like you're about i ca i have to
have someone bounce off of and you can
bounce off yourself
which is just crazy because i've never
been able to do that
yeah man i talk a lot so it's kind of
easy to do
especially when i have a lot of things
on my mind i like to get into debates on
twitter
me and you know what's funny every time
i make a debate you know who joins my
conversation
crap and the funny thing is i've never
been on a crap podcast he's never
invited me on the podcast or anything
but every time i say something about
xbox that's positive
he joins and try to do something
negative and we go back and forth which
is just wild to me
but um but yeah man i'm ready man i'm
ready to get back in the podcast game
i'll be back i'm trying to
get all my stuff in order uh for super
paw shots take podcast actually is
probably gonna be retired
um because it's just very difficult to
build a team and and be consistent with
that team
and it's just a lot easier to do things
by myself so i'm probably just going to
go solo with some
possibilities i don't realize how hard
this podcasting stuff is it's not easy
like this i feel like you just show up
and talk
no you don't yeah i spent an hour and a
half preparing for the show
like you don't i talked to you last week
about coming on the show like you gotta
you gotta prepare people to come on you
gotta have the
amount of time for someone to come on
you got you got especially i
you know i mainly do this with you know
one to two uh other people every week
like like imagine like doing it like
four people every week
like right and the host literally got to
keep everyone in check right
you got to always reel people back god
always make sure people doing what they
supposed to
like so i was shout out to cognito man
because uh being a host is not easy
that's why i gave it to
man i was like here i was here yeah cog
does a great job as a host on
iron lords without question yeah so we
we let
let's get to the the thing everyone here
seem to have came here for cal
is wb games
looks like it might be up for sale again
i don't necessarily know
if it's up i don't think it's up for so
publicly
but i definitely feel like they talk to
people privately right now
uh it looks like they have people
wanting to buy the company but not wp
games
here's the problem you have with with
this
the last time microsoft was interested
in buying warner brothers
there was a rumor going around that
warner brothers wanted to sell
the batman franchise and another
franchise but
not lord of the rings they didn't want
to give up the lord of the rings
franchise
like they own certain franchises and i
think that if you're going to go in and
cop
those games or cop that division you
might as well take
everything um and obviously dc
would be under warner brothers and you
could do some things with that
um i think the bat i think the batman
games are like
just drawn out at this point i feel like
it's time for them to move on if i was
microsoft i would concentrate on a green
lantern game
i just feel like a green lantern game
with the xbox green is perfect
i could just see a holiday commercial
with xbox neon green and then that
lantern pops up in green
you know what i'm saying and you maybe
you could play as hal and you could play
as
john um in different lanterns and fight
all the different lantern cores
you know i just think that would be
really dope
if they were able to pull that off
somehow i think that'd be pretty amazing
if they were able to pull that off
um you obviously are going to have the
lord of the range franchises
um and to me honestly there's not much
you could do with all of the rings other
than what they've already been doing
with uh you know the more dark with the
moldor series which is like the prequel
kind of to uh the actual lord of the
rings
book um but
i mean what can you do unless you start
creating new stories
in that world you know what i'm saying i
feel
i feel like when it comes down to it
i think they need rock steady just for
the talent
uh you know because they can make that
comic book because regardless what
people want to
want to say they need an answer to
spider-man they just do like
they need their own comic book i put it
up put it on the subway thing
you know i i don't know what it would be
i don't know green lantern
i've always thought a spawn game would
be cool but
yeah i said that as well spawn would be
excellent uh spawn has been on xbox
before actually as a character remember
back in the
uh today soul calibur had spawned yeah
yeah it was pretty good actually had the
uh
the gamecube version of soul calibur to
play as length that was fire
yeah i love that man those are the good
old days you don't see stuff like that
anymore
nah you don't you don't that was it was
pretty dope but uh
imagine now with cross play oh man i'd
be fired you play playing a link and you
know you can't play that link at all
like you can't play this link
you got spawn on there i think
playstation had high cheat from tekken
um yeah it was dope man it was dope it
was though back in the day
um i just feel like uh microsoft getting
warner brothers doing batman school i
just feel like they got to expand
you see obviously playstation has
spider-man
um and that works for them i think
we've had a lot of batman games already
like spider-man on playstation is only
in his first iteration in a way
you have miles morales obviously has
like a dlc
type uh type of title you know
but i think like what is it like the
third or fourth batman and now you got
the
batman family yeah
like the batman family is coming now and
batman's supposedly dead and
everything like that that's cool and it
looks dope i just feel like
dc has so many big characters like i
would love
maybe even a teen titans game would be
dope when you get to switch out yeah
that'd be cool
with teen titans you know play as uh
blue beetle lords like just
random uh superheroes within the
universe man
especially we're not going to get a
superman game which i'm still
disappointed
that we haven't gotten a superman game
yet as a superman fanboy
i think they need that for real i feel
like
the biggest thing they need is i've been
told by a few people that
they want to make a killer instinct game
they just don't got a studio for it
and give it back to uh well iron galaxy
what's the problem
i think iron gal i don't know if there's
bad blood between them anymore like
it's it's not they said that uh they
said they would be willing to do one
yeah
at the end of the day i feel like if
they bought if they bought
wb they'd get they'd get uh netherrealm
and i think netherrealm would make a
killer instinct
because like because if if they bought
the studio they would get netherrealm so
they might as well put another room to
work at that point
like another realm would be fire but
it's got to keep the same engine
i think they would there's you can't put
you can't give him the mortal kombat
engine and i'll be honest with you the
problem with mortal kombat for me is
some of these combos are
too damn hard to pull off like some
combos
in mortal kombat are hard as hell like
the angles you gotta hit
to pull them off in the timing you have
to have whereas killer instinct
a lot of their combos i won't say are
simplistic
but you once you get it going you kind
of know what you're doing and how it
flows
so i kind of feel the way they do those
things i think what killer instinct
needs
which i would say netherrealm is really
good at is building a
great storyline mortal kombat the last
motor combat storyline was
absolutely insane and it was time
to do this absolutely it was really well
done
and i tip my hat off to them because i
think they did an excellent job with
that
you could you could do killer instinct
in a very similar fashion you just have
all these weird characters
you got you you got people coming back
from the dead you got
robots and aliens it's just a wacky
wacky plethora
of characters and to tie that all to
some crazy story
would be pretty dope i think what would
be cool is
if they buy if they buy this and they
get warner brothers which you know this
is a huge if like
chat don't expect them to buy warner
brothers
if they do buy it like my my one of my
concerns is
that they're just gonna overextend too
much i'm sure they're already having a
hard time managing what they already
have but
we'll talk about here in a second but if
they get if they're able to get
netherrealm i think the best thing they
can do is the first game they make is a
killer instinct versus mortal kombat
yeah that'd be dope and then you
introduce the killer instinct to the
mortal kombat fans
and then you make just a straight-up
killer instinct game the problem with
that is does that game
become a third-party title because you
got killer instant characters which are
owned by microsoft
you put that on playstation
i don't know uh you know but at the end
of the day like
i feel like sony's clearly going to get
their hands on the street fighter
one like it's it's pretty much a given
this time like they got evo now
i can almost guarantee you street
fighter is going to get announced to be
an exclusive playstation
the next do you think so that would be
terrible if they did that again
i'd be highly disappointed if they did
that again if they get their hands on
that street fighter thing man and they
have the opportunity to make a killer
instinct versus mortal kombat
exclusive and they don't that's
microsoft's fault
because sony got no issue taking away
fighters from your fan base and your
consumers and your
your customers you should have no issues
taking them for them
theirs look i'm i agree
i feel like you know what's good for the
goose is good for the gander
i just don't know if they will allow
that to happen
and i really am i would be disappointed
in capcom if they did it again it's one
thing
where you're like oh we didn't have the
funds and it was funded by sony
there's no reason especially capcom
because capcom has been doing extremely
well
they've said that they've made a hell of
a comeback financially there's no reason
why street fighter an x-ray fighter
should not be multi-platform
unless they unless sony is just money
hat in it i wouldn't be surprised if
they did
but if they did i'd be extremely
disappointed
all right so i see people already
talking about my statement with
the managing thing look if they buy wb
games
it's gonna be like what seven more
studios for them to manage
um matt booty's not going to be able to
manage all that he's already managing
15.
uh you know um pete hines is managing
all bethesda
so to me they're going to have to hire
more people and people
on here they're saying that you know
when it comes to it
it's just it's not a matter of just
hiring like
you have to build an infrastructure it's
got to work well like you can't just
hire people put them where they are
you got to make sure it works like and
that's why most people
they build up gradually they like if you
think about it
microsoft has grown
crazy amounts in the past couple years
i'm not saying a multi-trillion dollar
company can't do it they
definitely can do it it's just a matter
is who are they putting where
uh for you know people talking about
management clearly something was
going wrong at 343. we don't know we're
about to see what happens at e3 see if
the game looks better but there's
clearly
something going on there's people
leaving it it's not as easy as just
coming in
and hiring people and would you not
agree with that count
no i definitely agree you want to have
the right people in the right positions
leadership is always important when it
comes to game development
um you know it's definitely all about
managing your teams correctly
timing is important obviously with uh
covet this has had a significant impact
on our industry
and uh it's obviously slowed down and
delayed a lot of titles
but leadership is definitely important
so um yeah
i i you don't want to put too much
pressure on matt booty you don't want to
put too much pressure
on uh whoever you you bring in if you
were to hire warner brothers
i mean where to buy warner brothers um
and get some of these titles
i just feel like if they're going to go
that route they definitely need to hire
somebody
um that's going to be able to take why
that's why i've always felt like out of
all the possibility studios
shout out to delilah hd for the five
dollar super chat just supporting you
guys kello
what's up i've always uh i've always
adored delilah she's
she's been a great supporter of the
realm she she
she i i just i just like the positivity
like
that that people bring and delilah's
always been one of those people that
you don't ever feel like like threaten
being around her and i appreciate coming
in absolutely
absolutely she's uh she does a great job
over there
at uh uh grown woman gaming
uh she's been been in the industry for a
long time i lean on her sometimes when i
need advice
she always gives good advice so
definitely support her uh she's
definitely one of the people that needs
to be supported
so and they do a great job there the
ascent just got a release date
yeah supposed to be june 29th july is
29th july 29th
i can't wait for that game they said
it's like uh cyberpunk not cyberpunk the
game but like a cyberpunk game meets a
diablo
so i'm hyped about that that but before
i got
to the super chat you know that's why
i've always felt like
out of all the studios they publishers
they could buy sega was one of the most
logical to me there's things happening
behind closed doors that absolutely
would make that and plus if you bought
sega
you would get that publishing arm just
like you did bethesda
and they could they could self rest they
could do all their stuff over there on
their own too
and whoever's in charge of sega could
keep second in check
right now i agree i always felt sega was
the better
was the better the bigger or the better
japanese studio to pick up microsoft and
sega have been working together for a
long time
a lot of people don't know or have if
you don't know
they microsoft actually helped sega work
on a dreamcast
when the dreamcast released that's why
the xbox and the dreamcast was very
similar
back in the day when it came to you know
controller and design
and stuff like that so it was it was
pretty cool a lot of sega games released
on
the og xbox as well so i mean if that
partnership
was to somehow merge i would not be
surprised and i think that they already
have a great relationship
um obviously we have uh fantasy star
online
on the xbox as an exclusive and so far
they actually got the news
they got the new content on there as
well that released
so i just think that um sega does an
excellent job when it comes to
uh you know at least staying relevant
it's been
it's been a minute they really put out
anything big big big
but they should definitely i think if
microsoft worked with them there's so
many franchises microsoft could bring
back
and really help them produce got a
finalized superchat from sheila walker
wb
is a publisher too they are but i was
more referring to
like what i feel like would be more
beneficial to microsoft
now i'm not saying i'm not downgrading
wb by any means they're
they're very they're very quality games
over there i love the shadow of mordor
shadow of war games probably some of my
favorite
lord of the rings games of all time but
to me what microsoft needs more is a
japanese arm
they don't need another you know games
that appeal to the western market arm
they got plenty of that if i were to
pick between wb games
and sega it would be sega 99 of the time
and i feel like cal would probably agree
with that i do agree
uh look one of the things that i spoke
with phil about one-on-one a long time
ago was i was telling him how i thought
that what made the xbox 360 great and
what attracted me to the xbox
was when i discovered western rpgs as
somebody that grew up on playstation and
was in love with ps2 for all the
japanese rpgs that they had
it wasn't until that played nice to the
old republic that i finally
understood what a western rpg was and
then obviously from there you got
boulders gate
champions of norwrath um jade empire
so i started playing all these games
these western games and then i got
introduced to elder scrolls
uh which was uh i think my first i
played morrowind but i couldn't get into
it but i loved skyrim
um skyrim was my and it's crazy i think
mike
owns that now that's what i'm saying i
put 200 hours in the skyrim
when it had on 360. mass effect was
incredible
they just had so many western rpgs i'm
like
you know 360 was great because you had
all these western rpgs that appeal
a lot of people loved fallout on xbox
witcher was on xbox like it was just
crazy and i'm like
you guys should be looking at trying to
bob obsidian or you know i know
i know phil was upset that he missed out
on getting bioware
um that was one of the things that he
told me personally that that was
something that he
at the time when he could have bought
them that he didn't pull the trigger on
so i'm just like yeah and you know i'm
sitting here to think about it man if he
would have bought that which you know
obviously is a domino effect
i would prefer this realm of reality
we're in than just buying bioware they
could have felt a little bit more
comfortable and they never pulled the
trigger for anything they're doing now
but they would have bought bioware they
had that all the entire mass effect
trilogy
as an exclusive uh maybe further going
on dragon age
maybe microsoft wouldn't have you know
interfered as much that ea did when it
come to making future titles like mass
effect andromeda
maybe that would have been cremity that
wouldn't have gotten done uh anthem
probably would never exist
that would be that would be a phenomenal
future
right right right right but that's what
i'm saying i just felt like
you know and then to turn around and
have them cop
all of these big western rpg studios and
in exile and obsidian and they own
almost all of them
that's the only one they own that's what
i'm saying like they basically own them
all it's
incredible it is absolutely incredible
to me
and when i uh when i found out and i
kind of went through it i just
tipped my head off the field i hit him
up i said listen man you did an
excellent job
you literally have your yours
your first party basically runs
the best western rpg studios in the
industry like as far as popular ones
they're almost
couple but the like they have obsidian
which i was talking to cognito
it's crazy what obsidian's made obsidian
has made uh
uh they made south park stick a truth
completely random rpg
then they made uh couture ii then they
met fallout new vegas
then they made uh pillars so they have
like that diablo-style type of game
and then they made the outer worlds they
have literally been in almost
every rpg genre you can think of yes
absolutely and they've always been very
popular games
all those games were hit yeah and then
and exiled guys were part of that team
a long time ago like they split into two
they split into two right so like you
just have these
these groups and you got the bethesda
squad now
back together it's like you've literally
united this broken family
that made all these amazing western rpgs
and now they're back together
they could they could talk to each other
they can learn from each other
they can create ideas off each other and
i wouldn't be surprised if microsoft
tried to do a new new vegas
with obsidian at some point i feel like
you know obviously we've definitely got
off this ain't going to be too much
longer guys but
um i feel like they need to give fallout
to another
uh another one of the studios like look
like
i'm not saying bethesda can't make it
but does it could definitely they've
showed they could make fallout games
i'm saying because they got too much on
them now they got the elder scrolls they
got if starfield goes anywhere they got
that
like let someone else make fallout and
give them
get it off them i mean it's tough i i
know you
i know they would want to give it to
obsidian but obsidian literally has out
of worlds which is like
i don't want to give up city i want to
get into exile like i want them down
and exile i feel like they they can make
a quality fallout game with the right
funding i
if obsidian wanted it i'm not going to
tell obsidian know
you know what i'm saying like if it was
up to me in obsidian wanted to make it i
would let them make the fallout game
but i don't think obsidian wants to make
a fallout game i think they want
they want to make their own stuff for
for years
generations obsidian has made other
people's games
right and i think now that they're
finally in a situation
and they they're in a better spot
especially financially they can make
whatever they want and i think
that's more important to them than
making falla but then again
i don't know they might they might have
really loved fallout new vegas and they
want to make fallout i don't know
we'll see that's why i'm kind of looking
forward to avow is one of my most
anticipated games
fable as well using the forza engine and
it's funny
because i i remember having a
conversation on take podcast
and i was like could you imagine if they
made an open world game with
forza horizon this world and i'm like
the
like the sandbox alone is incredible the
skies the way they design the
the world and all that stuff like that
it's just really really awesome
um and and and just to think that's just
a driving game
you know that's just a driving you know
like an arcade driving title i'm like
imagine if you eliminate the tracks in
the cars and just have people
walking around and you're doing missions
in different areas and that's exactly
what it was going to be
that's exactly what fable is going to be
and they've hired they
yeah my only thing is i hope that fable
doesn't look like fable
i want fable to look like a new ip thank
you
you know so many people attacked me over
that because i made a video and i said
in the videos like look i know people
like the cartoony look i know people
like
like the british humor thing but to me
that's never been fatal
fable has been the decisions the world
being designed around your decisions
to me that's fable like i want a dark
grimmy fable that when you choose
something it drastically
has a ripple effect across the rest of
your placement
well the thing is we know that that
british humor is in there because they
introduced it in the damn and that's
fine
the british chamber has always been
something that was optional it's not
something you had to
like you were forced to do right right
right right but yes
the decision making in the game is
what's most important and
i feel like i hope that they make it to
the point to where
the decisions that you make in the game
actually have a real
impact on the game as you're playing and
not so much you have to wait to the end
to see what happens
i think that'll be pretty cool um and
and and
those decisions should transfer from the
gaming from game to game
of mass effect i think that would be
really dope they were able to pull that
off
but i just really want fable to grow up
a little bit i want it to be a little
bit more mature
um i don't mind the magic i i really
want them to have
a plethora of weapons a crafting system
would be incredible i love crafting
um weapons i wouldn't even mind if they
did like um
like crafting map ingredients like you
know kill this monster to get these
weapons
look at that the comment section already
on my ass yeah okay all right
i get it like like there's
i'm a fable fan man you go look at my
achievements i beat every fable
i've played a lot of fable in my life
and i don't mind that they went that
direction
but to me i feel like in order to make
fable
go ahead go become like one of those
things where
it it revolutionizes that entire genre
it can't be what fable used to be it
could have the fable
aspects and the foundation that fable
was built on
but i don't think that fable can get to
that next level like that witcher level
as the fable that we played back then
that's just my opinion
yeah i mean i i think that uh i don't
know
i i think that it's possible but i just
think that uh
i think that michael i think that uh
fable just needs to be
a just a bit more mature just more than
anything you can keep the british humor
um i just feel like that the combat
needs to be
more uh
more varied you know not just your basic
one two three hit
block dodge and then your magic attack
it just needs to be more varied and i
think that
it needs to uh it needs to be a a
variety of weapons
in a deep a deep system a deep combat
system would be great too
yeah and i definitely uh 100 agree with
that
so you know we're going to go ahead and
uh start closing up man uh yeah i
definitely appreciate you coming on
where can the people find you cal where
what what's going on
oh man you know right now uh again i'm
still on hiatus i'm still
taking some time off um i will be
returning in august of 2021 i don't have
a particular day yet
um but superpower shots will be the new
flagship podcast for me and a new
flagship
uh podcast for uh
i guess you could say my network um
again i'll probably be going solo
uh tick games network as a website still
exists it's up and running
um we'll obviously going to be
recruiting some new people and having
those guys come in to continue
putting out new uh news and content for
you guys
but as of right now uh i'm working on
just getting my son out of school trying
to get him out of school
hopefully these covet restrictions lift
up a little bit
and uh he'll be going back to school in
august along with my daughter and i'll
have some free time to myself during the
day so yeah
the podcast will be during the day won't
be at night um
and uh you guys can catch me sometime in
august just keep an eye out
on tick podcast you can catch me on
twitter
at tic underscore podcast tic underscore
podcast
which will soon be switched to super pod
shots and uh again yeah you know you
guys know me cal
yeah i see people in there man lord
addis responds another
butcher game i never said that man i
love the witcher universe
i just like okay nico said like 80
mature 20 funny right there that's all i
want well i think that's
it like you guys can say what you want
and i get it like
obviously from one witcher fan to
another we have different aspects of
what we like
i didn't really i didn't care for the
british humor i i liked what you're
for what witcher was as a whole with the
foundation the
the the fact that when you're in the
spiral like if you don't give them what
they want they torture you for 10 years
and
and you come out your face is all messed
up like that is the aspect of
the fable that i loved right look i mean
nobody said that it can't be whimsical
you can have
all of the mystical things the the doors
that talk to you no i want all of that
i want all of that i have all of that
the only thing that we're asking
is that the game takes on a more mature
style of gameplay you know what i'm
saying like you got to think about how
fable was back in the day you would have
to bluster bus gun
or a pistol you got a sword um you had a
magic attack
a lot of that stuff was real basic if
you think about it you know your
your your sword attack was like your
basic two or three hits
there was nothing like there was no
combinations to it there was nothing
deep about that
your guns were really basic or generic
pistols
shotgun rifle you know there was no
variance in those type of guns back back
then you know
um i don't even know if they had
crossbows in the game i can't remember
i think they did did they uh and then
you had like you had magic and magic was
kind of like generic as well
like and then you guys got to think like
favorite been around in years
it's the competition's way more in that
genre like like you you got to evolve or
you got to shut up
like you you're looking at a game like
that release if
it releases the same way it released
back
then people will kill fable like the one
thing we talk about is how
fable a lot of people be like gears
hasn't evolved enough
that's why gear supposedly is fading out
because it hasn't evolved enough
even though they've been trying to make
changes to the game fable has to evolve
you can't compete with these other rpgs
that's doing all these amazing things
if you're still doing the same basic
stuff so like you know your character
models need to mature
your world overall needs to mature your
decisions need to mature
um you know there needs to be some type
of crafting system
um some some some type of loot system
that gives you some amazing games or
amazing weapons or amazing drops
you need to have an armor system you can
still marry your
you know marry who you want to marry
whether it's male 1 because all that's
fun to have kids like all that stuff is
fine we just want a mature rpg
and it's like i said the competition's
more on that and i i will end with this
i want a fable franchise not just one
fable game
and the best way to have a fable
franchise is to compete with all the
other stuff everyone else is doing
you can't come out with a game that was
made in the 2000 and expected to to fly
now
you can't you've got to evolve it but
anyway i appreciate everyone for coming
by
just get me out of we're out of here
peace